good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight rahm emanuel may be a
Democrat in one of the most democratic
cities in the world but that doesn't
mean he is popular there the city of
Chicago is falling apart in a lot of
ways you may have read it is deeply in
debt over 50 billion in debt there were
six hundred and fifty murders there last
year most of the schools are genuinely
terrible he would not send your own kids
under any circumstances so not
surprisingly schools polls rather of
Chicago voters from last year showed
Rahm Emmanuel's approval rating at about
25% and with numbers like that there is
no chance he will be reelected next year
but like a lot of unpopular Democrats
Rahm Emanuel has a plan to keep himself
in power if he can't win over existing
voters and he hasn't been able to he can
create new ones
Chicago is rolling out a new government
ID card called city key a few months ago
a manual explained that city key is
intended to bring illegal immigrants
quote out of the shadows city key is
designed to Fort federal law enforcement
the cards don't store personal
information ice can't use them to
enforce federal law and that's
intentional now Chicago has announced
that these cards which were designed for
legal aliens can be used for voter
registration in other words non citizen
illegals will be able to vote in the
city of Chicago including in federal
elections that affect you now that's
illegal
Congress passed a law against it is
explicitly illegal and yet the city is
encouraging it when a reporter asked two
aldermen Gilbert Villegas about this all
if he made it clear he didn't care
quote there's nothing stopping someone
from getting a fake ID now and going to
try to vote he said and that's true of
course but there is a significant
difference between ignoring voter fraud
which is wrong and abetting it which is
horrifying
authorities in Chicago want ineligible
voters to vote now why would they want
that as the Chicago Tribune pointed out
it's pretty simple Rahm Emanuel wants to
get reelected if it takes illegals to do
so fine whatever it takes we contacted
the mayor's office for comment today
about this they did not even bother to
respond the Justice Department for some
reason doesn't seem to be doing anything
about any of this and it's not just
happening in the city of Chicago in a
state of California illegal immigrants
get driver's licenses hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of them and they
can
use those to register to vote and some
doubtless do in the state of Maryland
some towns are trying to legalize voting
for illegal immigrants how long it's all
that's a Democratic Party platform plank
how long until some federal judge and I
don't know Hawaii declares that
preventing illegal aliens from voting is
racist and demands they get the vote
immediately nationwide it's coming of
course it is the left wants power and
this will give it to him Chicago
Alterman and may Apple are sponsored the
bill creating the new IDs and he joins
us tonight mr. Olin and thanks for
coming on thank you for having me so do
you support non-citizens voting I think
there's a misunderstanding of what the
city key is it is a library card it's
access to our mass transit it is a
municipal ID that gives people who are
exiting homelessness the opportunity to
present an ID where a driver's license
or state ID might be too expensive and
it also is available to our undocumented
neighbors but let me be also clear in
order to force someone to register to
vote they would have to sign an
affidavit and present a birth
certificate a passport a social security
card and potentially this so you'd still
need a second form of ID and if you
fraudulently if you defraud the Chicago
Board of Elections the Illinois State
Board of Elections and you are
undocumented you are subject to
deportation so this is not a right so
you're just I just want to get this on
the record because I you're factually
inaccurate here but I just want to hear
you say it to me so you're saying that
in order to register to vote in the
state of Illinois you need to produce
evidence of citizenship is that your
claim yes it is I also think it's
important to recognize that what you're
suggesting is that the City of Chicago
the Illinois State Board of Elections
the Chicago Board of Elections and
undocumented neighbors are all
coordinating with one another I'm not
I'm not suggesting I'm not suggesting a
conspiracy and I want to get back to my
original question in just a minute which
is do you support non-citizens voting
because I think will be interesting to
hear your view of that but I'm not
suggesting a conspiracy I'm merely
saying that when you let illegal aliens
use this card which was designed in part
for them and don't be disingenuous and
pretend otherwise that would be a
as you know the mayor bragged about it
when you let them use this card to
register to vote when in fact you are
not required to show proof of
citizenship to register in Illinois
you're wrong you have to say that you're
a citizen you'll have to prove it you're
a betting voter fraud and you know that
it's simply not true I've know the rules
to be a voter registrar there are laws
in place and frankly I just don't feel
like it makes sense to turn communities
in to the other see in Chicago we like
to celebrate our neighbors we like to
say not it's not a question of
celebrating your neighbors you can
celebrate someone appreciate them take
them to dinner while still understanding
that only citizens are allowed to vote
and so let me ask my question for a
third time do you think non-citizens
should be allowed to vote in our
elections the federal law state law says
that only citizens can vote and the idea
I'm not going to sit here and get to
play a game where we're gonna design a
game documented people I'm asking you
very simply what do you think there's a
federal law passed in 1996 it's in the
US Code that said that it says that
non-citizens cannot vote in federal
elections they're allowed to vote of
course right
I believe de la do you believe obviously
you don't believe in federal law because
this city card the ID that you made
possible is explicitly designed to
prevent federal immigration authorities
from enforcing federal law suit
obviously you don't believe in some
federal laws but I just want to know
what you think do you think if you could
make the law would you allow is the
theoretical matter non-citizens to vote
I mean that there are no of course now I
mean we have laws on in the books to
make sure that citizens can vote I just
don't believe in demonizing undocumented
neighbors I don't believe in turning
people into the other right that's just
not how I run my office this is not why
I ran for office the son of immigrants
well I'm a son of immigrants and when I
hear that's relevant you were born in
this country you're a citizen so I guess
the question is not do you like all
people here that's a totally separate
category the question is is there a
meaningful difference between a citizen
and a non citizen and you're trying to
erase that difference okay so what would
be the difference is what do you think
should be the difference is what should
citizens get that non-citizens don't
well I mean there are lots of
non-citizens by the way who pay taxes
there are lots of non-citizens on
document and neighbors who serve in our
army but your weirdo lied past my
question again it's not a referendum of
whether they're nice people or whether
some of them add a lot I mean I agree
with these I'm going to give them their
lives okay that is absolutely true but
I'm asking you a much deeper question
and you may not get this in your
political life often but it has to a
citizenship which is the foundation of
the country so what is the distinction
between citizens and non-citizens what
does citizens get that non-citizens
don't why is that a meaningful
distinction well citizens have access to
a social security card and some more
access to our social safety net and
we've those distinctions have always
been in place which is why people work
so hard to come here to become a part of
our American fabric that's what my
parents came here I just don't believe
that you know these dog whistles and I'm
not suggesting you're making them what I
am saying is that people around the
country what do you mean by dog so what
does that mean what I mean pet dog
whistle is that there seems to be a
national rhetoric to pit poor white
people against poor black and brown
pieces the you actually I'm sorry that
you and I know you've got a history of
race baiting so I'm not surprised you
did that but I just want to ask you
let's be real this is Chicago Chicago is
not a city where anybody's trying to win
a lot of poor white voters
african-american voters are dissatisfied
with the mayor and everyone I know who
covers Chicago Chicago politics says
this is an effort to basically ignore
them in favor of a new class of voters
some of them non-citizens so it's not
about whites on any level these don't
bring it to that's not true it's just
not true there is no grand conspiracy
between Chicago elected officials the
mayor's office the Board of Elections
and people in the city to say let's do
fraud but what is the city I mean this
is the actual foreign interference in
our elections the idea that foreigners
could be voting so you're doing a lot
for legal aliens in your city what are
you doing to prevent them from voting in
elections so let's also be clear there's
one evidence that the Russians foreign
influence is meddled in our elections
well there's your
Warners are voting in our elections so
what are you doing about it if you care
about foreign interference
I mean hey I want to know why the core
batch Commission was disbanded because
they were certainly looking for all this
information about what are you doing it
just gave an ID card to people here
illegally in violation of our laws and
you're letting him use that card to
register to vote what are you doing I
mean my family was my family will have
that ID card and we'll use it to go
check out books at the library just like
someone else will I'll get it I'll use
it to get on a train I mean this is a
municipal ID which is different from all
those things but you don't to ask the
question I petition mr. alderman we're
out of time